in today's meeting ministers had the
opportunity to discuss the agenda head
of the spring European Council which
will take place on the ninth and tenth
of March 2017 and which would revolve
around the creation of more jobs growth
and competitiveness as well as security
the spring European Council will also
address the issue of migration as a
result of the Declaration adopted last
Friday during the Malta and former
summit the new clan will seek to support
the agreement reached between Italy and
Libby Olive Street the discussion will
also cover legislative priorities and
major strategies including those to
deepen the single market in all its
aspect the digital single market
strategy the capital markets union
action plan and the energy onion on our
agenda we also had a presentation from
the Commission on its communication
concerning the next steps for a
sustainable European future spring
European Council address the issues and
will provide the impetus for further
progress today's council helped in to
make sure that we will bring better
quality of life to our European citizens